has obviously a black man how sorry when
I say I'm colorblind I mean I'm like
physically culture and as a conservative
who one does not believe in my privilege
I don't believe that exists and as
someone who believes in individualism
and does not believe that he is a victim
you know I'm obviously have in my
opinion the greatest university but how
do i basically combat other primarily
other blacks who basically call me names
you know the classics you know all the
time oh that could all that jazz and how
do i combat that and basically say
explain to them how they like me are not
victims so I mean I think that the first
thing that you have to do is something
that you've already talked about which
is just you have to say you're an
individual I'm an individual let's stop
talking as black people and let's start
talking as individuals now as an
individual would you like to succeed in
life would you like it is what you
should say right you say do you want to
succeed in life because it because
you're obviously succeeding but there
are a lot of people who are not and one
of the great barriers to success is
feeling that you're a victim and feeling
that society is putting you behind the
eight-ball
how about try my way for a year I try my
way for a year where you ignore these
societal obstacles that face you and you
just put your nose to the grindstone and
you work really hard and I promise you
there gonna be a lot of people out there
who are willing to help you and want to
help you and want to see you succeed and
no one has ever gotten ahead by by
complaining about the society itself the
way that you get ahead in America at
least in a free country right in an
oppressive country then maybe this helps
but in a free country then the only way
you get ahead is has an individual you
know if someone wants it first of all I
think that it's someone who tributes a
name to you like that
the first thing that you can say is that
says you know your Uncle Tom I think the
first thing we should say is well no
you're an so because because
there's more evidence that are an
than the year and Uncle Tom
and I mean that very seriously
slurring people without evidence is one
of my least favorite games and if
somebody slurs you that way I'm not sure
you can honestly have a great
conversation with them anyway
but I think that when you treat people
as individuals there's a there's a
certain seductive nature to that because
everyone in the end wants to be treated
as more than their skin color I think
you're doing a great job of that right
now I think I'm probably talking to a
future senator from the state so so
thanks for coming thanks for asking the
question
[Applause]